Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten.
Linus, ich will jetzt mit der Sendung anfangen. Hast du deinen Hund auch genommen?
Damit ich extrag gutes Netz habe, habe ich sogar doppelt verdünnt.
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer 439 vom13. was war jetzt? September.
Ja, dreizehnten September zwanzig zweiundzwanzig. Ist dir was aufgefallen? Es war 11. September und keiner hat mehr über nine eleven geredet.
Ja klickt auch rückblickend betrachtet gar nicht so dramatisch oder? Wenn man sich die Situation heute anschaut.
Also.
Was war da los? Ach ein Flugzeug,
Ihr habt Probleme.
Nee, aber also ich bin ja ich ich bin ja nicht nicht äh positiv gestimmt.
Ich weiß, du, du, du äh hast jetzt auf Spiegel Online gelesen, das war die beste Gegenoffensive seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg und glaubst, das ist alles vorbei jetzt.
Äh das habe ich schon äh gedacht, bevor es auf Spiegel online stand. Die wollen ja eher ein bisschen spät dran,
Ich hänge äh derzeit so ein bisschen voll äh Warjunkie mäßig da in meinen Kriegstimes und äh verfolge das Geschehen mehr oder weniger in Rildheim und äh ja,
da, da ist grad die äh äh Action, das äh raubt gerade ein bisschen meine Aufmerksamkeit, meine Allgemeine.
Du meinst, dass du meinst, der Krieg ist dieses Jahr noch vorbei.
Äh ich denke auf jeden Fall, dass die Russen's jetzt nicht mehr lang machen. Also das der hat fertig. Der Russe hat fertig.
Da bin ich ja echt mal gespannt. Also.
Die haben die die haben die die haben die wirklich an den Eiern jetzt und das ist äh,
Also es wird sich noch etwas hinziehen so, ja, aber das sieht gar nicht gut aus. Äh die Liste ist lang. Also wir haben ich rede ja mit Pavel nach wie vor über UKW. Über den Krieg. Wir haben uns auch grad nochmal eine,
rausgebracht, die sich mit dieser ganzen äh jetzt aktuellen Offensive äh behandelt und ja wenn man sich das anhört danach, wisst ihr auch,
warum ich dieser Meinung bin.
Ist Krieg kann alles passieren, klar, gar keine Frage äh vor allem für unerwartetes. Das ist jetzt im Prinzip auch gerade passiert, aber die haben den halt jetzt einfach ihre Hauptversorgungs äh Route komplett,
geraubt und äh die haben jetzt dann doch äh echte Probleme,
sich überhaupt noch zu versorgen und denen geben demnächst einfach die Waffen aussehen, fallen ja sowieso schon die Panzer auseinander und äh die haben jetzt auch so viele verloren, äh so viel übergeben sozusagen, also mittlerweile ist ja Russland der größte Waffenlieferant äh.
Das ist echt kein Witz. Also die in den letzten Wochen haben die denen also mehr Panzer geliefert als Deutschland überhaupt bauen könnte in dieser Zeit. Also.
Mit so einem Kammer mit so einem Panzer dann einfach umgehen, hat der keine Wegfahrsperre oder so?
Ich glaube, wenn er eine Wegfahrsperre hätte, na dann dann dann würden die da nicht äh mit vorwärts kommen. So Kriegsgerät, das muss sich halt jederzeit unter jeder Bedingung äh aktivieren lassen. Da kannste nicht mit so einem.
Zentralverriegelung.
Ja ja.
Alarmanlage.
Ganzen Schlacht folgt.
Okay, mal ganz ehrlich, ne, früher oder später musst du aus dem Panzer raus. Du musst mal pinkeln, äh vielleicht willst du auch mal woanders pennen. So, da würde ich schon erwarten, also wenn ich einen Panzer hätte, ne?
Wenn ich drin bin, würde ich mich jetzt erstmal halbwegs sicher fühlen, aber ich ich wäre schon froh, wenn ich wenn ich mal raus muss, wenn ich den abschließen kann, weil ist halt Kacke, wenn dein Panzer unabgeschlossen irgendwo rumsteht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass der ein Schloss hat.
Meinst du echt dich?
Alter, dann verlierst du den Schlüssel oder was? Das ist doch einfach unpraktikabel.
Ja, aber so verlierst du den ganzen Panzer.
Wenn Leute so nah rankommen, dass sie dir irgendwie dieses Schloss aufmachen können, dann ist eh schon zu spät. Also das das bringt einfach gar nix.
Also keine Ahnung, ob die deutschen Panzer oder die amerikanischen haben bestimmt irgend so ein Tunnelf da drin, aber die russischen Panzer, das ist einfach Beerborns Zeug. Das ist einfach,
Maschine, Rohr äh Munition zack gib ihm da wird äh keinerlei Komfort geboten, schon gar nicht denen, die da drin sitzen,
Da willst du auch definitiv nicht drin sitzen da in diesen Munitionskarussellen, das sind ja einfach alles Selbstmord.
Wenn wenn du in Deutschland irgendwie eine Pistole besitzt, ne, dann musst du dir auch wegschließen und einen Panzer stellst du dir in den Garten und da kann jederzeit jemand einsteigen und irgendwie äh mit rumfahren?
Läuft das halt anders.
Ich glaube inzwischen muss man sich Gedanken machen, ob man das in Zukunft noch mit Treckern darf, so wie die Ukraine mit den Dingern umgeht, ne? Also die werden wahrscheinlich jetzt auch demnächst äh irgendwie unters Waffenkontrollgesetz fallen, aber ähm.
Trecker rollen wieder auf jeden Fall. Gibt gerade wieder viel abzuschleppen. Also ernsthaft, das ist jetzt genauso wie da äh bei der ersten gescheiterten Offensive um Kiew herum. Und jetzt äh,
übergeben die Russen äh ihre ganzen Bataillone en Block, also,
irgendwie fünfzig, 60, 70 Panzer allein heute irgendwie nochmal gemeldet worden und zahlreiches anderes Gerät also,
Munitionslager. Es ist äh die haben jetzt richtig Sackgang. Das äh alles wird gut.
Ja, dein Optimismus ist wunder wunderschön, he? Aber ich habe, glaube ich, auch heute Morgen in Deutschland von gehört, dass Wladimir Putin mit telefoniert hat,
Das macht er ja glaube ich auch nur, wenn er also das ist ja irgendwie die Hoffnung, ne, dass das äh,
dass dass man durch äh ausreichend nieder äh Niederlagen auf äh ukrainischen Boden Putin ans Telefon bekommt und ihn äh mit ihm verhandeln kann.
Die werden nicht mit ihm fahren, denn keiner wird mit dem mehr verhandeln. Also die auf jeden Fall nicht. Vielleicht Olaf Scholz oder Sarah Wagenknecht, aber bestimmt nicht die Ukraine.
Also das ist halt ähm ja, ich kann nur hoffen, dass ich jetzt äh das Blatt im Westen dann endlich final,
wendet und danach sieht's ja jetzt auch schon,
aus, dass einfach jetzt verlieren sie langsam äh aller den den Schiss, dass dass der Russe den deutschen Panzer äh bekommt und sich genauer anschauen kann,
Jetzt ist das Ding halt durch. Also die die kriegen einfach keine Verstärkung mehr ins Land und die werden jetzt einfach am langen,
ausgerundert, Hunger hat und äh das war's dann.
Okay, ich bin gespannt. Ich bin tatsächlich gespannt. Ich habe davon keine Ahnung. Ich ich bin bin Pazifist und Kriegssitzverweigerer.
Ja, na ja, das sind die Leute, die jetzt nicht weiterhelfen gerade.
Die Kriegsdienstverweigerer, du kannst ja in der Ukraine ja gar nicht.
Ja und die Pazifisten auch, also zumindest die bestimmte Art von Pazifisten, die so der Meinung sind, man müsste alles äh sein lassen.
Ja, dass äh der Meinung bin ich nicht, aber äh dass da jetzt alle Pazifisten drunter leiden müssen, dass einige Leute unter dem Deckmantel des Pazifismus
der Ukraine des Selbstverteidigungsrecht absprechen äh finde ich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt richtig.
Ja genau,
Nun ja, aber wir sollen ja hier beim Thema bleiben, auch wenn immer keiner so genau sagen kann, was äh das Thema eigentlich ist, irgendwas mit Netzpolitik, ähm,
Auf jeden Fall äh helfen wir immer äh bei akuten Netzproblemen, wie auch Hundeorien, Pforte.
Der heutigen Sendung, bestellen Sie jetzt äh unter mit dem geben Sie beim Checkout äh was was muss man sagen.
LP vier3neun an. Oder einfach nur LNP. Ja wir haben ein tolles wo kam das her?
Und dann kriegen sie zwanzig Prozent auf alles, außer Tierurin.
Ja, also du hast äh du hast das irgendwie als Erster äh gesehen auf Twitter kam das, ne, das Bildchen.
Genau, ja. Hat äh äh ein hat uns ein Foto geschickt von einer äh Hundolien Pforte 24 Tabletten,
bei akuten Netzproblemen äh in der N eins ja also die N1 sind vierundzwanzig Stück genau.
Das Ende eins.
Ist doch bei Medikamenten immer das die gibt's in der in eins, in zwei und in drei.
Ah, wirklich. Mhm.
Ist Familienpackung N eins ist äh ja genau.
Also Ende eins ist sozusagen, wenn man sich selber irgendwo nicht einloggen kann, wenn der ganze Route ausgefallen ist und die Kinder nicht mehr nicht mehr äh wie äh nicht mehr spielen können.
N drei ist wenn irgendein irgendein BMW-Fahrer mal wieder einen Diesel umgefahren hat, dann brauchst du N drei.
Ach so, das ist ja für die ganzen Blog sozusagen. 2 ist für die Familie. Okay. Verstehe.
Ja okay, das das kann man auf jeden Fall nehmen und gibt's gibt's im Shop und äh gibt's auch im Abo für Leute, also für Leute aufm Land gibt's das im Abo. Ähm dann haben wir Feedback.
Ja, wir haben wieder irgendwas nicht gecheckt und nicht gewusst.
Also alles wie immer. Genau. Marcel äh hat uns hier gefeedbackt in den Kommentaren äh und schreibt tatsächlich ist die Identifikation mit,
online aus. Also es geht um Post-Ident. Tatsächlich ist die Identifikation mittels Online-Ausweisfunktion im Rahmen von inzwischen möglich. Das habe ich selbst vor einigen Wochen,
positiv festgestellt, als ich meine Persönlichkeit für die Eröffnung eines Bankkontos nachweisen musste.
Dabei ähm hat's mich allerdings.
Muss einen Persönlichkeitstest machen oder.
Haben Sie auch die richtige Einstellung für so einen Bankkonto?
Sie eigentlich über Banken an sich?
Bisschen, bisschen zu extra für extrovertiert für für diese Dispo.
Ich lese mal noch ein bisschen weiter dabei äh hat es mich allerdings einigermaßen irritiert, dass die Post Ident ab deren Installation mir während des Identifikationsprozesses für das,
beste Nutzererlebnis nahegelegt wurde. Nutzererlebnis, auch so ein Wort. Die Kommunikation mit meinem Personalausweis mittels NFC-Schnittstelle meines iPhones und folgte ich auch die Entgegennahme meiner PIN selbst erledigen wollte.
Ich habe mich dann dagegen entschieden, die Post Ident abzunutzen und die Identifikation im Browser durchgeführt, da die Post Ident Webanwendung im Gegensatz,
die Ausweis-App zwei zur Durchführung der Identifikation nutzt.
Diese Variante wirkte auf mich deutlich seriöser. Wenn ich davon absehe, dass die Weiterleitung an die Ausweise-App zwei in meinem Fall erst funktionierte, als ich nach kurzer Google suche, die Protokoll Sektion des Links von der HTTPS zu EID dort,
änderte. Äh okay, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, warum du jetzt da Probleme hättest, die App selber äh zu.
Weil weil die Post-App natürlich jetzt theoretisch die PIN speichern könnte. Aber äh ja ähm.
Also dazu glaube ich nur zwei Kommentare äh der Prozess, den du da ja jetzt schilderst, Marcel ist äh glaube ich klar, dass hier die meisten die meisten Leute dem nicht folgen und äh das Problem ist ja auch tatsächlich,
wenn du sagst, du möchtest deine Identität möglichst sicher nachweisen gegenüber der Post, ist das ja schön und gut. Wenn sie aber dem ein
weniger sicheres Verfahren anbieten
dann können ja die Menschen, die vielleicht nicht ihre eigene Identität, sondern die einer anderen Person nachweisen möchten, sich immer können dann immer das unsicherere Verfahren nehmen, ja? Insofern ähm,
gilt hier, glaube ich, so ein bisschen die Regel von dem,
von dem schwächsten Glied und wenn wenn du ein das schwächste Verfahren anbietest, gerade beim Identifikationsverfahren, dann musst du dich eben nicht wundern, dass äh die meisten Leute das schwächste Verfahren nutzen. Das ja zugegebenermaßen,
auch wirklich ähm komfortabler ist, also gegen den Komfort kannst ja wirklich nix sagen. Also eine eine Sache muss man sagen,
Dieses äh Video Event, das ist komfortabel.
Wenn du genug Licht hast und und was da dich alles machen muss, aber komfortabel ist es, ja. Es ist halt nur ähm,
wohl nicht sicher. Allerdings,
bin ich ja selber eigentlich nicht unbedingt gewillt, bei einem Identifikationsverfahren notwendigerweise, unbedingt das sicherste zu nehmen, ähm wenn ich die freie Wahl habe.
Ähm und er hat's ja jetzt auch weiterhin im Kommentar kritisiert, dass er natürlich sagt, äh wenn die die App hat ja,
also muss man vielleicht auch noch vorlesen. Der sagt hier nur hier wäre kein Keylogin notwendig, sondern die User werden dazu erzogen ihre Zugangsdaten in beliebige Apps.
Einzutippen und äh bei wenigen ist dann die der Unterschied zwischen zwei Dingen äh den bekannt und er hatte natürlich Recht, so wird äh Phishing äh Tür und Tor geöffnet. Hat er hat er einen Punkt, ja? Insofern hm,
Von der Sicherheitsüberlegung macht es schon durchaus Sinn, dass immer und nur über die Ausweis-App zwei zu machen, aber äh gut,
ähm.
Noch mehr Sinn würde es natürlich machen, wenn die Betriebssysteme diese Ausweisfunktion,
Selbst äh durchführen und dass dann man sozusagen so,
Personalausweis in sein Telefon quasi in so einen secure Element äh reinpacken kann und sich dann so wie man das jetzt mit Kreditkarten auch schon macht äh dann mit biometrischen,
Absicherung identifiziert und dann quasi das Betriebssystem der App als,
Interface sozusagen den Zugriff darauf äh ermöglicht und dann,
eine Online-Identifikation damit äh sicher durchführt, ohne dass irgendwo was in so eine App reingetippt werden muss, weil das quasi das Betriebssystem dann äh sicherstellt, dass die Identifikation korrekt ist.
Es wird auch kommen, das gibt's das gibt's auch schon äh in den USA jetzt mit dem Führerschein, der ja da im Prinzip quasi der Personalausweis ist.
Hatten wir in Deutschland ja auch zwei Tage lang. Nur halt ohne Securement.
Ja und ohne dass es im Betriebssystem drin war, genau.
Ja und und ohne dass es funktioniert hat und ohne dass es sicher war, aber im Prinzip war der Safe auf. Also der war tatsächlich auf, ja. Äh,
Christian äh hat gesagt, ich er hat jetzt das Papier mit der TransportpIN für die EID-Funktion rausgekramt und äh dass die Ausweis-App zwei habe ich fast durchgespielt.
Allerdings habe ich auch erst seit einigen Monaten ein Smartphone mit NFC,
davor wäre es schon daran gescheitert. Äh der Login bei Elster funktioniert instantal ohne dämliches Zertifikat, genauso die Auskunft beim Kraftfahrtbundesamt,
bekommt die Auskünfte sogar direkt als PDF, das Führungszeugnis wird allerdings per Post zugeschickt und kostet auch dreizehn Euro.
Auskunft zu Stasi-Akten kann man auch mit EAD online machen. Okay, du hast es wirklich durchgespielt.
Außerdem kann man äh PGPs per EID signieren lassen,
Dann sagt er doch, ob eine sechsstellige, selbstgewählte numerische PIN dem Perso, allerdings ausreichend schützt,
schon etwas fraglich. Da werden viele ein Geburtsdatum verwenden und auf dem Ausweis selbst befinden sich diverse Zahlen, die sich anbieten würden. Selbst wenn nicht, besteht reale Gefahr durch Phishing Kiel oder Kameras,
oder den klassischen Blick über die Schulter. Äh immerhin braucht man nach drei Fehleingaben den Entsperrcode. Ja, lieber Christian,
mit äh drei Fehleingaben und Entsperrcode oder einem dann gesperrten System,
schützen wir seit vielen Jahren Kreditkarten und Bankkarten und da sogar nur mit vierstelligem Pin. Insofern ähm,
also dies die Risikos hinein, die du hier benennst, äh alle korrekt, aber die skalieren halt bei weitem nicht so schön wie eine Videoident ähm insofern ähm,
auch noch mal richtig, also komplette richtig erfasst. Äh streng genommen, identifiziert man sich ja gar nicht mit der EID. Äh,
wenn's zum wenn zum Beispiel kein Abgleich mit einem Lichtbild stattfindet. Man beweist nur, dass man Kontrolle über die erlangt hat.
Äh mit Papis Perso könnte Fritzchen keine Zigaretten kaufen. Das habe ich aber anders erlebt im Ruhrgebiet. Da hat Fritzchen auch ohne Pavispa so Zigaretten gekauft. Äh.
Mit der ist die gewollte oder ungewollte Nutzung durch andere Personen in jedem Fall leichter. Ja da also das äh,
Ähm,
leicht also wir reden ja hier von zwei komplett unterschiedlichen Anwendungsfällen, nämlich überhaupt online und dann muss sich die E-ID ja äh vergleichen lassen mit Systemen wie äh Videoident oder sonst was und,
Ich denke, für den Fernnachweis,
der Identität ist die äh aktuell wahrscheinlich das sicherste Verfahren, was es gibt. Unter den mit den Einschränkungen, dass natürlich trotzdem noch ein Abgleich mitm Lichtblick stattfinden muss und so weiter.
Ähm aber äh Bafög kann man damit auch beantragen habe ich gesehen. Tim.
Also ich habe jetzt mich tatsächlich ich glaube das Muster ist jetzt gerade mal überprüfen,
wie ist das jetzt hat sich auch gelungen mich bei Elsa mit meinem Perso einzumelden mit dieser Funktion. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass es besonders elegant äh abläuft, aber äh funktioniert, hat es tatsächlich.
Also,
Das erste Mal, dass ich das äh erfolgreich zum Einsatz gebracht habe. Nicht, dass ich jetzt unbedingt auf Elster äh gerne meine Zeit verbringen möchte, weil es das überlasse ich dann doch irgendwelchen äh Apps, die da eine Zertifikatsdatei hinschmeißen, aber ähm ja mhm
Immerhin. So, Technologiedemonstrationen äh durchgeführt, ein bisschen klamm sie halt mit diesem komischen Ausweis Ausweise App.
Zwei Ausweis-App zwei. Warum heißt das Ding Ausweis-App zwei?
Als die zweite Ausweis-App ist.
Warum heißt es nicht einfach Personalausweis? Das muss einfach ins Betriebssystem rein. So äh ist jetzt einfach zu Horny.
Genauso wie bei Elizabeth.
Ist auch die Zweite. So äh BAföG Online hat mich.
Queen-Witze jetzt.
BAföG online hat mich die Tage dann doch sehr überrascht. Die haben die aus online Ausweisfunktion echt gut mit dem aktuellen Stand der Digitalisierung deutscher Behörden kombiniert. Bei beim Einloggen musste ich mich mit dem Personalausweis identifizieren.
Darauf konnte ich dann im Menü einen SEPA-Antrag stellen. Der beinhaltete eine gefertigte Nachricht an das Amt mir doch bitte ein Papierformular
für den SEPA-Antrag per Post zuzuschicken, welches sich dann aus.
Ein sinnvoller Einsatz der online Ausweisfunktion.
Ja, das geht voran Tim. Das geht voran.
Das ist super.
Dann äh wurde uns noch ein Link zugespielt, denn ein KI generiertes Bild hat einen Kunstwettbewerb gewonnen und Künstler sind angepisst. Es war keins der Bilder, die ich generiert habe.
Wobei die in bestimmten Kreisen sicherlich auch Preise gewinnen könnten.
Ja
gewisse Kreise. Du sagst es. Ja das finde ich ja äh wirklich interessant und überrascht mich auch überhaupt nicht, dass die Künstler sich da aufgeregt haben.
Auf einmal Leute mit so einem modernen Zeug kommen, das ist ja alles ist ja alles kann ja gar keine richtige Kunst sein, wenn er das nicht äh wirklich im im im nassen Keller mit schmutzigen Fingernägeln ins Wachs gekratzt wurde.
Totaler Unsinn, ne? Weil es ist natürlich eine künstlerische Leistung, sowohl im Prozess als auch im Ergebnis.
Ne, also gut, ich meine, ist jetzt nicht so mein nicht so mein Style von Kunst hier so, aber sieht halt,
ja bemerkenswert äh aus, also es handelt sich hier um,
hat also mehrere Bilder eingereicht, davon hat halt 1 gewonnen weiß nicht, wie man das jetzt beschreiben soll, so von der Optik her. Das hat so ein bisschen so was,
Periode meets äh meets Sissi ähm,
Gefühl ähm,
Ja, aber das hat dann äh im Ergebnis äh gefallen. Ich bin mir auch nicht so sicher, inwiefern ähm dass der Prozess den bewertenden, zu dem Zeitpunkt,
schon bekannt war sieht das hier aus dem Artikel vor.
Ja also was das habe ich das,
äh das auf Leinwand gedruckte Wild ist wirklich beeindruckend, lalala. So,
Ellen hat für das Bild keinen Pinsel in die Hand genommen,
noch nicht einmal einen Digitalen gemalt hat das Bild die KI-Software mit Journey. Allan gab die Befehle. Vor allem auf Twitter diese Herangehensweise für Empörterektionen äh,
gesorgt. Künstlerinnen und Künstler warfen Ellen vor, dass Aussterben kreativer Jobs voranzutreiben. Ich mal ich weiß halt nicht, die Frage ist halt dieser L jetzt den den äh Preis verdient?
Ich meine, das ist doch dieselbe Diskussion, als Leute angefangen haben mit Photoshop-Bilder zu machen.
Man konnte ja von einem auf Leinwand gedruckten Bild ich meine die werden ja jetzt wohl nicht gedacht haben, dass der das selbst gemalt hat, weil dann hätte man ja Pinselstrich und Farbe da drauf gesehen und das muss ja schon äh offensichtlich gewesen sein
dass dieses auf Leinwand präsentierte Bild so nicht aus,
einer Federfloss, sondern im Rahmen eines technisch an der technischen Reproduktion dort präsentiert wurde, sonst wäre ich jetzt total überrascht. Und äh mit anderen Worten, das muss ja dann auch,
ähm möglich gewesen sein in irgendeiner Form. Es ist ja auch die genau, die Kategorie, da stehst du auch. Kategorie digitale Kunst. So.
Moment, der ist halt ja also digitale Kunst ist ja eine Sache. Er also er sagt, dass er sein Werk beim Einreichen klar als Jason Allen war ja mein
mit Journey gekennzeichnet habe und betonte, ein weiteres Mal den menschlichen Anteil an dem Kunstwerk. Ich generiere Bilder mit Mit-Journey, überarbeite sie mit Photoshop und rechne sie mit Gigapixel hoch.
Ist doch hervorragend. Ich meine, das ist ein künstlerischer Prozess, der arbeitet halt mit anderen Mitteln.
So wie so wie man vom vom vom Pinsel auf äh die Maus gewechselt ist, wechselt man jetzt hier in in Kot so. Natürlich kann,
und die Kontrolle von Code, natürlich auch die Nutzung von anderer
Leute code äh nach wie vor einen künstlerischen Prozess abbilden. Ich meine, in welcher Maler stellt denn seine Farben selber her?
Also das das passiert ja immer sozusagen auf äh anderer Leute Werkzeugen,
Es gibt ja auch gar nicht den Anspruch, dass man jetzt sozusagen die vollständige industrielle Produktionskette im Griff haben muss, nur um irgendwie so ein Bild zu erzeugen, sondern es geht ja um den künstlerischen Prozess und dieser künstlerische Prozess, der ist ja hier auch nach wie vor
präsent. Du hast eine Idee, du willst dir deine Werkzeuge
die Werkzeuge äh erzeugen etwas. Du willst hier weitere Werkzeuge, verbesserst dein Ergebnis und führst es letzten Endes zu Ende, also,
Ich sage nur Applaus. Toll, super, weiter so.
NFT davon?
Mal gucken.
So, da hast du.
Schauen wie viel es davon gibt.
Dann die Schweiz gehört nicht zum europäischen Wirtschaftsraum.
Das ist richtig, das stimmt,
Weil äh der europäische Wirtschaftsraum ist nicht das, was ich äh in dem Moment äh dachte äh oder meinte äh mich darauf bezogen zu haben, sondern dass ich im Kopf hatte, war die
Efta. Die EFTA ist ja ein sehr überschaubarer äh Wirtschaftsraum. Es sind nämlich sozusagen die
ausgeschlossenen oder die nicht die die sonst nicht mitspielen wollen, also Norwegen, Island, äh die Schweiz und ähm,
glaube Lichtenstein, ne? Genau, also alles, was sozusagen nicht in der EU ist, aber auch irgendwie ähm mitspielen will und die haben sich dann halt, Entschuldigung, nee, warte mal, habe ich Recht, Island,
Lichtenschein Norwegen, Schweiz, genau. Das ist die FTA. Ein sehr sehr exklusiver Club.
Der steht für European Freetradement oder wofür steht das.
Ja. Europäische Freihandelsassoziation heißt es da.
Okay. Na ja, schön.
Da wollten die Briten äh also da haben sie drüber also ich meine ja im äh im Rahmen des Brexit sind natürlich über alles geredet. Unter anderem haben sie halt auch viel über äh geredet. Man kriegt ja dann vielleicht auch in die FTA eintreten und so.
Und äh als das so diskutiert wurde, meinten so die Norweger so nee,
Ihr seht bei uns auf gar keinen Fall ein irgendwie euch verpeilte überhaupt nicht im Club haben.
Um dann demnächst die ganze Woche mit euch zu diskutieren, dass ihr hier wieder austrete.
Ja ja und da irgendwie alles anders wollt und überhaupt. Also da da hatte irgendwie überhaupt gar keiner Bock drauf. So eine Null-Diskussion wie so viele andere, die da geführt wurden.
Ja, schön. Dann äh also ein weiterer Club, wo wo die Briten keiner haben will. Ähm kommen wir zum ersten Thema.
Hui.
In Deutschland beginnt jetzt die Einführung des E-Rezeptes.
Und da sind immer wieder Leute auf dich zugekommen, hey Linus müssen mal gucken, da ist wieder E-Rezept, da ist auch wieder Scheiße und ich ich habe muss sagen, dass ich das Thema so ein bisschen äh,
gehofft habe, ich könnte es durch ignorieren ähm wird das wieder weggehen,
Ist aber nicht so, denn ähm das beginnt jetzt äh schrittweise seit Donnerstag, glaube ich, letzte Woche bis zum Frühjahr,
20 23 soll es den äh Papierzettel verpflichtend ersetzend ersetzen. Dann gibt's nur noch E-Rezept.
Natürlich wurde das konzipiert mal wieder, solche Dinge werden ja immer konzipiert von der Gamatik. Äh die GEMAtik ist so ein Zusammenschluss, der dann diese äh der diese Standards schreibt, ja, sind die Krankenkassen drin.
Und ähm was weiß ich, wer da noch mit drin ist, der dem Staat gehört der Teil zum gehört das zum Teil. Mal kurz gucken, aus wem sich die GEMAtik zusammensetzt. Äh über uns.
Karriere über uns. Karriere will ich nicht machen, du. Äh.
Die Gesellschafter der Thematik sind das Bundesministerium für Gesundheit und die Spitzenorganisation im deutschen Gesundheitswesen, welche sich in die beiden Gruppen Leistungserbringer, in Klammern Ärzte, Zahnärzte, Psychotherapeuten, Apotheker, Krankenhäuser, Hebammen,
Physiotherapeuten, Rettungsdienste et cetera und Kostenträger,
klaren Krankenkassen, die privaten Krankenversicherer äh hatten zwischen 2012 und April 2020 keine Gesellschaftsanteile unterteilen lassen. Also ist sozusagen so ein,
Sammelsurium so einen Gesamtverband der medizinischen ähm,
ja das medizinischen Gesamt des Gesundheitswesens im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Das sind diese Wesen.
Lesen. Ja, jetzt sagen die, machen wir eh Rezept. Und,
Überlegen, was was sind die wenn du ein wenn du ein Rezept baust, ne, dann muss ja irgendwann baust du erstmal,
eine Ärztin äh die in der Lage ist das das zu signieren, damit nicht irgendjemand ein Rezept fälscht von von einer,
Stelle, die nicht zur zum Ausstellen des Rezeptes berechtigt ist,
Wer diese Podcasts schon länger hört, wird jetzt sofort merken, dass es eigentlich alles sehr viel mit Impf es ist sehr ähnlich wie Impfpässe, ne? Ähm
Impfpässe dürfen bestimmte Leute ausstellen, andere nicht. Du willst irgendwie die Berechtigung prüfen, dass sie ausstellen dürfen. Du willst keine zentrale,
Datensammlung davon haben und dann kommt aber noch ein Aspekt hinzu, nämlich im Gegensatz zum Impfpass, sollte das Rezept möglichst nur einmal eingelöst werden,
Ähm aber am Ende gibt es, geht es hier net, ne, um äh,
um ein einerseits ein ein Dokument, das signiert sein muss von einer zur Ausstellung berechtigten Stelle, was dann von einer,
von einer anderen Stelle geprüft werden muss, nämlich einer äh zur Ausgabe berechtigten Apotheke, ja, die dir die die dir das Medikament dann gibt und dann muss das irgendwie noch,
im Zweifelsfall 'ne Rechnung geschickt werden.
Und dann hättest du und dann muss irgendwie dieses Rezept irgendwo vermerkt werden als ähm,
ungültig oder als als eingelöst, damit du nicht mit einem Rezept hier zweimal äh Zeug holst, ja. Eigentlich relativ überschaubare Sache. Ähm kann man kann man hinkriegen, vor allem,
man da natürlich mit ähm äh,
mit einer dezentralen Infrastruktur arbeiten, weil du musst immer nur Signaturen prüfen oder verschlüsseln, ja? Das heißt, da da bietet sich wieder an
einfach schön alle Daten in das Rezept rein äh mit den entsprechenden Schlüsseln verschlüsseln, mit den entsprechenden äh Schlüsseln signieren,
und dann äh zentral einfach die Seriennummer oder den Identifier des Rezeptes äh als als ungültig markieren, ja?
Wer wer aber zu einfach gewesen.
Nicht was mit Blockchain machen.
Hätte man auch mit einer Blockchain machen können, da haben sie zum Glück gesagt, das ist äh das wäre äh Unsinn, aber.
Was.
Die TI baut also die die Telematik Infrastruktur, die TI, die stehen ja, das sind die mit den Konnektoren, ne? Haben wir glaube ich auch hier schon öfter drüber gesprochen. Die haben so ein Gefühl, werden wir auch bald wieder drüber sprechen.
Ähm dass ihr die mit den Konnektoren. Die wollen natürlich die die wollen zentralisierte äh Systeme bauen
Ja, das ist äh Selbsterhaltungstrieb natürlich auch, der da äh stattfindet und gewissermaßen brauchst du schon, also,
Wahrscheinlich echt eine Blockchain machen mit den abgelaufenen Rezepten äh oder mit den eingelösten Rezepten. Äh um das erste Problem zu lösen, denn äh es hat hier eine Analyse,
CCC stattgefunden primär von Flipke, Flipke war ja auch schon bei uns in der Sendung. Ähm zu welchem Thema denn damals.
Äh das ja mhm.
ID Wallet, ID Wallet, genau. Ähm schön,
Äh bei einem Ausfall zentraler Dienste der Telematik-Infrastruktur,
wie zuletzt im Jahr 2020. Wäre es wochenlang unmöglich E-Rezepte einzulösen?
Oder bei einer wie geplant verpflichtenden Einführung des E-Rezeptes die Papierverfahren für den Havarie, äh ob,
bei einer äh wie geplant verpflichtenden Einführung des E-Rezeptes die Papierverfahren für den Havarie oder Katastrophenfall bestehen bleiben,
ist ungewiss, also haben das Ding sogar so gebaut, dass jetzt einen zentralen haben, der wenn kein Internet gibt oder deren Dienste mal wieder ausfallen, dann gibt's eben keine,
keine Einlösung von deinem Rezept, was äh sehr elegant ist. Dann haben Sie das äh bewerben Sie es wunderschön mit folgenden Worten. Die E-Rezepte werden von der Arztpraxis verschlüsselt an einen zentralen Dienst übertragen,
Dort verschlüsselt gespeichert und verarbeitet und wieder verschlüsselt von der Apotheke abgerufen.
Damit sind die E-Rezepte vor unbefugten Zugriff Zugriff geschützt. Man denkt natürlich, die wären jetzt durchgängig verschlüsselt. Aber die Verarbeitung erfolgt,
unverschlüsselt und jedes Mal, wenn in diesem Satz der Begriff verschlüsselt vorkommt, reden wir von einem neuen,
ähm Verschlüsselungsvorgang, also es wird der Eindruck erweckt,
Ähm es man hätte ja eine Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung, das ist aber nicht der Fall. Äh stattdessen äh gibt es jetzt einen zentralen äh eine zentrale V,
AU die vertrauenswürdige Ausführungsumgebung, in der die Daten dann.
Entschlüsselt und verarbeitet werden, aber natürlich äh wieder auf eine Weise, dass die Anwenderinnen das nicht prüfen kann, wie vertrauenswürdig äh dieses System,
tatsächlich ist. Ähm und wir haben dann eben eine zentrale Sammlung von äh Gesundheitsdaten unter sowieso mit dem neuen digitale Versorgungsgesetz, aber spezifisch hier auch mit dem ähm,
E-REZ. Also Vertraulichkeit mangelhaft. Schauen wir uns an.
Ich ich freue mich jetzt ich meine im Rahmen dieses also vielleicht sollte man nochmal sagen E-Rezept das klingt ja mal so ein bisschen wie so irgendwas, was jetzt mal so eingeführt wird oder so das existiert ja schon. Das wird auch schon benutzt und zwar wenn man bei diesen Onlineapotheken,
sich irgendwie
online von irgendeinem Arzt äh beraten lässt, gibt's ja, ne, online äh Ärzte et cetera, die dann äh meistens an diese oder ich weiß nicht, ob es meistens ist, aber unter anderem auch an diese Onlineapotheken, also diese Docenorys und,
alle heißen Teleklinik und so. Äh die anderen tatsächlich so Ärzteteams und dann kannst du da halt da mit denen irgendwie auch deine äh Issuus besprechen. Ähm
und dann stellen die dir halt unter Umständen auch ein Rezept aus,
Tatsächlich zur Apotheke und kann sich da dann direkt abholen, ohne zu einem richtigen Fleischarzt irgendwie latschen zu müssen.
Ich gehe im, also so krank war ich noch nicht in letzter Zeit.
Aber also muss ich tatsächlich sagen, habe ich keine habe ich keine Ahnung, aber hier geht es jetzt also ich ich weiß nicht, was diese DocMorris da machen,
Ich kann nur sagen, das ist der einzige Standard, der jetzt von der äh Bundesregierung, von Karl Lauterbach vorangetrieben wurde und von der Gatik.
Die machen genau das. Also die benutzen das E-Rezept. Meiner also sie reden zumindest von explizit von E-Rezept,
Das ist das, was die zustellen. Und ähm das heißt, da wird das auch schon benutzt. Die haben das sozusagen auch für sich schon implementiert. Das Problem ist halt nur, dass,
alle Ärzte das sozusagen auch noch machen müssen. Und was jetzt äh diese Verschlüsselungs äh Geschichte betrifft, was wir im Prinzip beschreiben ist ja so eine Art Transport äh Verschlüsselung, ne? Das heißt, die Daten liegen an verschiedenen Stellen. Aber sie müssen ja auch an verschiedenen Stellen,
eingesehen werden können, weil da ja auch dann die Abrechnung der Krankenkasse mit dranhängt et cetera. Ne, also da kenne ich mich jetzt ein bisschen zu wenig aus, ähm nur,
mal so als Anmerkung.
De facto wird einfach alles an die Thematik verschlüsselt und da musste dann dem da musst du dann vertrauen, da liegt alles zentral. Äh das ist auf jeden Fall nicht notwendig,
Ja? Das ist das äh dafür kann man,
dezentrale Systeme bauen. Dafür hat man Verschlüsselung. Wenn du alles auf einen zentralen Haufen wirfst, brauchst du auch keine keine ernstzunehmende durchgängige Verschlüsselung. Aber es geht ja noch weiter, ja? Wenn du.
Das E-Rezept jetzt mit der elektronisch elektronischen Gesundheitskarte in einer Apotheke abrufen möchtest,
Und das jetzt zum Beispiel gar nicht so blöd, dass man sagt, okay, das äh Rezept wird an die an deine Gesundheitskarte,
ausgestellt und du bist dann mit der Gesundheitskarte in die Apotheke gehen, ja? Jetzt muss die äh muss die Apotheke aber nur bei der Thematik die Krankenversichertennummer angeben,
und es erfolgt aber keine,
technische Prüfung, dass wirklich die Karte da war. Das heißt, du kannst äh als Apotheke äh die die zum Beispiel auch einfach in irgendeine in irgendeine,
also die die abtippen ja oder kannst du über Videoideen machen, ja? Und äh da,
wäre natürlich, ist natürlich auch wieder sehr skurril, wenn du ja diese Kartenlesegeräte hast und deine ganze Thematikinfrastruktur.
Und ähm hier sagt sogar der äh Chief Security Officer der Gamatik der E-Rezept-Fachdienst,
kann weder die Integrität,
noch die Authentizität eines Prüfungsnachweises überprüfen. Es liegt in der äh Verantwortung des Apothekenverwaltungssystems die Abläufe gemäß den Anforderungen umzusetzen,
So baut baust du so ein System nicht, ne? Also dein die GEMAtik kann nicht prüfen,
ob ob irgendjemand wirklich die die EGK vorgelegt hat. Das muss die das das wird da zur Pflicht der Apotheke.
Also meiner Kenntnis nach läuft das mit diesen E-Rezepten, bei diesen Online-Diensten, bei diesen Online-Apotheken so, die stellen dir das Rezept aus. Du sagst bitte zu der Apotheke und dann ist das sozusagen auch genau bei der Apotheke, da kannst du das dann abholen,
Da ist dann auch nicht mehr erforderlich, als zu sagen, ja guten Tag, ich bin Peter Meier, da müsste ein Rezept für mich liegen.
Ich bin mir wirklich nicht sicher, Tim, ob diese Doc Morrisse die Telematik-Dienst nutzen. Ich kann es, ich weiß es nicht
Ich war nicht bei einem Doc Morris, aber ich kann nur sagen, das ist hier ein Telematik-Dienst und ich wäre ein bisschen verwundert, wenn der seit längerer Zeit von irgendwelchen syriotischen äh Online-Drogenhändlern äh verwendet wird.
Tatsache ist, dass die in Deutschland an Apotheken E-Rezepte, also elektronische Rezepte, sagen wir's mal so, ja.
Dirk Moris, die schicken dir den Shit doch nach Hause. Ich glaube, du bist irgendwie.
Nein nein, wenn äh etwas verschreibungspflichtig ist, dann kann das nicht dann muss das von der Apotheke ausgegeben werden,
Ich rede jetzt nicht von Kopfschmerztabletten, sondern ich rede von etwas, wo ein Befund hergestellt werden muss, wo ein Arzt sagt du,
brauchst dieses Medikament. Deswegen rennst du doch zum Arzt. Der Arzt schreibt ein Rezept auf, weil du das nicht selber in der Apotheke kaufen kannst.
Du willst es vielleicht auch auf Rezept haben, weil du's dann auch erstattet bekommst? Aber es gibt ja auch Sachen, wo du zuzahlen musst oder die überhaupt nicht erstattungsfähig sind, die aber trotzdem verschreibungspflichtig sind.
Und solche verschreibungspflichtigen Dinge kannst du auch bei diesen Onlineapotheken erwerben. Nicht alles, aber
manches und äh dann hast du's da wirklich mit einem online Arzt zu tun, entweder halt in Form von Video äh Kommunikation
oder in manchen Fällen auch einfach so ein Formular, wo du sagst, ja äh wie nee, keine Symptome, das nicht, aber ich habe die Beschwerden, Pipapo
zack, Return, dann äh geht da äh
Deine Mail hin, dann kriegst du jeden Tag später oder ein paar Stunden später kriegst du dann äh kriegst eine Mail. So ja äh schön, sie haben ja alles richtig äh ausgefüllt äh dann äh hinterlegen wir ihnen jetzt das Rezept und das können sie jetzt irgendwie bei der
abholen.
Ist es denn denkbar, dass trotzdem die Nachricht stimmt, dass seit dem 1. September 2022 das E-Rezept der Gematik ausgeholt wird, wie ich's überall lese? Äh also es.
Ich sage nur, ich sage nee rede nicht von dem, ich sage nur so existiert das heutzutage in Deutschland, das ist jetzt real, äh Secondhand Information.
Okay, dann können wir also lass uns vielleicht trotzdem dabei bleiben, was das Problem mit,
E-Rezept ist, was jetzt grade ausgeholt wird von der Thematik nach dem digitale Versorgungsgesetz, welches am 19. Dezember 219 in Kraft getreten ist,
und das wird jetzt ausgerollt und verpflichtend gemacht und es ist von der Thematik. Ich ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung. Es kann sein, vielleicht machen die Doc Morris so was besseres, vielleicht sind die auch gar nicht sitzen die gar nicht auf Zypern?
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich würde nie bei denen bestellen, weil der Shop aussieht wie wie was, wo ich nicht bestellen würde.
Sagen wir mal so, es gibt da so bestimmte Produkte, die die Leute gerne haben wollen und wo sie vielleicht auch nicht so gerne zum Arzt gehen.
Über 20 Jahre. Ich sage ja, das sind das sind in im Zweifelsfall sind das die gleichen Leute, die die einem die ganze Zeit Viagras beim schicken oder?
Na ja.
Also, okay, die haben sicherlich auch einen Weg. Tim, lassen sie uns ganz kurz äh vielleicht bei der Gamatik bleiben, weil das ist ja, das ist äh es kann sogar sein, dass Doktor das Gamatikding schon umgesetzt hat. Ich weiß es nicht. Ähm,
Das Entscheidende ist ähm wir haben jetzt hier mal wieder eine komplette ähm eine komplette.
Weißt du, wo man was hätte richtig machen können und sich entschieden hat nicht richtig zu machen. Ähm und,
Hier also erstens sagen sie dann, die Apotheken sind, äh die müssen die Abläufe gemäß den Anforderungen der Gamatik umsetzen. Geile Digitalisierung des Gesundheitswesens, wenn du zentrale,
Aspekte der der Sicherheit und der Integrität des Verfahrens an irgendwelcher Apotheken gibt's,
Hat auch schon bei den bei den Impfpässen so gut funktioniert, ja ähm und ähm,
Chief Security Officer sogar, äh dass solche Maßnahmen äh äh das ist logisch, wer das solche Prüfungen eben über überwindbar sind.
Sie würden das aber absichtlich so machen, was äh ich ehrlich gesagt fachlich nicht,
nachvollziehen kann, wenn die Leute halt eine eine Karte haben, deren Präsenz zu überprüfen kannst. Das macht ja der Arzt äh oder die Ärztin genauso. Und der Knüller ist, ähm,
die das, was du dann als QR-Code hast, ja, was dein E-Rezept ist.
Das ist noch nicht mal das vollständige Rezept, sondern eben nur eine Referenz auf deren zentrale Datenbank. Entsprechend wird auch empfohlen,
Äh du solltest den Patientinnen eine vollständige Version des E-Rezeptes Menschen und Maschinen lesbar aushändigen. Äh stattdessen äh hast du jetzt einen QR-Code,
der äh offene zentral gespeicherte Vollversion des Rezepts verlinkt. Also es ist wieder so eine,
weißt du, das kann ja sein, dass irgendjemand das so macht und ich habe auch schon vor vor vor zehn Jahren oder wann ähm als es darum ging,
Als die D-Mail eingeführt wurde, da war ich zu der Anhörung im Bundestag zu dem,
Justice Gesetz, ja? Und dann habe ich gesagt, dann haben sie gesagt, hier, da könnt ihr jetzt mit der Demel eine Klage einreichen, wo ich auch sagte, so, ich kann mir nichts schöneres vorstellen,
ne und dann habe ich gesagt, hier das ist aber, ne, das ist einfach kein vernünftig gesichertes Verfahren,
Und dann war da äh ein anderer Sachverständiger, der ähm da war, um um dieses Verfahren irgendwie gut zu finden und äh sagte dann, eine Klage können Sie auch auf einer Postkarte einreichen, ja?
Stimmt wahrscheinlich, also die meisten Klagen passen nicht auf eine Postkarte, aber vielleicht ähm ne, theoretisch, wenn deine Klage, wenn du nur wenig klagst, dann passt das vielleicht auch auf eine.
Und habe ich ihm gesagt, so pass auf
wir können von mir aus dann können wir dann brauchen wir auch keine D-Mail zu bauen, wenn wir sagen wir wollen irgendetwas machen, dann können wir ja unsere Klagen einfach mit der Web DE Grußkarte einreichen.
Ja? Das ist doch alles also man will doch, wenn man was Neues baut, hier wieder Milliarden ausgegeben werden. Alle Ärztinnen und Ärzte gezwungen werden, den Mist dann nachher umzusetzen, ja nachdem sie sich neue,
TI-Konnektoren gekauft haben. Ja ähm dann kann man doch auch ein vernünftiges System bauen.
Ja, klar. Also vernünftiges System.
Ja äh mal eins, wo man irgendwie,
Also es ist es ist in meiner Wahrnehmung ist das jetzt hier den es ist ein E-Rezept zugegebenermaßen, ist nicht ganz so einfach wie ein äh wie ein Impfnachweis, ja? Der Impfnachweis soll ja äh von allen geprüft werden können und so, da gibt's ein paar Unterschiede, ja?
Aber so ganz grundsätzlich,
Der Grundgedanke, dass nicht zentral irgendwo zu speichern und sich einen Singlepoint of Failia zu bauen, der der sollte doch eigentlich sich auch bei den ähm,
bei den bei den bei denen jetzt so durch umgesetzt haben. Wir können die Diskussion noch nicht jedes Mal neu führen,
Und es gab ja damals die Diskussion, dass gesagt wurde, hey, wäre das nicht sinnvoll, wenn wir einfach ein Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung macht?
Wie gesagt, du hast ja auch noch die Anforderungen, dass ja diese Daten, diese Rezeptdaten müssen ja auch noch an die Krankenkassen weitergeleitet werden.
Ja, wunderbar. Äh haben wir vor, weiß ich nicht wie viel vor 25 Jahren gelöst. Äh Multiparty äh Verschlüsselung. Ja, dann sagst du halt verschlüsselt das Rezept halt,
mit drei Schlüsseln, einen für die äh für die äh Krankenkasse ein für die Apotheke,
einen vom Arzt. Von mir aus einen für die Apotheken des Landes oder wo auch immer, ja? Aber äh du musst ja nicht äh sagen wir speichern jetzt alle Rezepte.
Zentral bei der bei der Gamatik.
Wenn das am Ende soundso viele Krankenkassen äh oder private äh Krankenversicherung und ein paar Apotheken was angeht.
Aber Linus, du weißt doch, IT-Sicherheit ist nicht alles.
Das war nämlich der Konter. Der Konter der ich bin da heute durch Zufall drüber gestoßen ja so einen harten Konter hat der CCC ja lange nicht äh gehabt, ne. Da weil,
die die die Gematik hat die CCC-Kritik gekontert. Da habe ich ja gedacht so boah Konter! Also unterm Konter stellt man sich ja so was vor wie jetzt hier äh,
ganz Ukrain, so. Habe ich gedacht, junge Junge, jetzt kommt aber hier der Konter. Wer weiß,
jetzt kommt die ne oder die Konterrevolution. Wer weiß, was jetzt alles kommt und ähm dann war ich ja sehr gespannt. Und äh zwar hat die Gamatik gesagt, das E-Rezept ist sicher.
Denn,
IT-Sicherheit ist nicht alles. Ein Ende zu Ende verschlüsseltes E-Rezept wäre weniger praktikabel. IT-Sicherheit ist nicht alles, ist also der der Slogan,
von denen, die grade das Gesundheitswesen digitalisieren,
Und ja, man kann natürlich sagen, ist jetzt nur ein Rezept und wird's ja nun mal eben die Kopfschmerztabletten abholen oder die Stärkeren.
Bei den Weisheitszahnen gezogen wurde oder was sich alles, ne, man kann auch sagen, klar, die äh ähm Apothekerin oder der Apotheker, die dir dann dein Viagra geben, die sehen Eva CD geben. Richtig, aber hier wird zuerst mal eine zentrale Datensammlung eingeführt dafür,
Das äh erscheint mir einfach mal wieder nicht nicht gut. Das einfach das einfach nicht nicht angemessen.
Wolltest du denn die Daten gerne gespeichert? Ich meine, letzten Endes werden sie ja bei den Krankenkassen ohnehin.
Der Gamatik. Ja richtig, aber wir müssen ja noch nicht bei der Gamatik gespeichert werden. Wenn du die bei ich weiß nicht, wie viele Krankenkassen es in Deutschland gibt, gefühlt irgendwie zwanzig, 30 große?
Viele kleine Betriebskrankenkassen und so.
So, da wird eine von denen aufgemacht, wunderbar, dann hast du die äh Rezepte von den Patienten. Du musst auch nicht bei Leuten, wo das Chile Security Officer ja offenbar sagt, IT-Sicherheit ist nicht alles, da willst du doch dann nicht alle äh,
alle Rezepte speichern. Das ist, es ist, was du hier siehst ist das typische,
und das beklage ich auch regelmäßig das typische Deutsche wir machen das System so komplex,
das wird richtig toll sicher. Und dadurch diese Komplexität und Zentralisierung baust du dir halt diesen ganzen Mist. Und ich fände es einfach wirklich schön, ja. Aber ich
versuche ja auch beruflich strebe ich ja immer wieder dazu irgendwo eine schöne ähm,
einfach zeitgemäße Infrastruktur zu bauen. Und das ist keine. Es ist einfach keine.
Na ja, Hauptsache man kann Hundorina mitbestellen, sonst äh.
Kriegst du rezeptfrei. Das ist ja ein Massenleidennetz Netzprobleme, kannst ja jetzt nicht irgendwie jedem noch ein Rezept abverlangen.
Ich dachte, das wäre verschreibungspflichtig.
Nix. Glasfaser ist verschreibungspflichtig.
Ja, das hätte ich auch gern mal ein Rezept. Da sollte man mal was machen. Ich habe ja auch Glasfaser.
Gibt's da nicht was von Ratiopharm?
Ohne IT-Sicherheit. Ach ja.
Okay, also aber wie gesagt, das ist ja nur das das ist ja nur das der kleinste Häuflein,
äh von der Klimatik, ne? Die haben ja noch ganz andere noch ganz andere Tricks auf unser Warten und äh da äh werden wir sicherlich äh noch einiges von hören in in nächster Zeit.
So, dann haben wir ähm.
Porno.
Das waren die mit Sitz in Zypern. Entschuldigung. Ich habe ja jetzt Doc Morris als Drogenhändler mit Sitz in Zypern bezeichnet. Da muss ich mich entschuldigen übrigens,
wo haben die hier einen Impressum auf dieser Website.
Die sind auf jeden Fall auch in Deutschland äh präsent, also da haben sie ihre.
Früher auch immer eingekauft. Okay, kommen wir zu den ähm kommen wir zu dem Porto Netsperren. Ähm die Macher äh mehrerer großer Pornoportale äh mit Sitz in Zypern.
Ähm weigern sich ihren äh ihren Webseiten, die sie der äh breiten Masse anbieten, einen Jugendschutz vorzuschalten,
der den Anforderungen der Kommission für Jugendmedienschutz genügt. Gewissermaßen.
Also es gibt auch einen Grund, warum diese Pornoseitenanbieter das nicht haben wollen.
Der beste oder der der äh also der beste Altersnachweis, der natürlich halt mal bitte deinen Ausweis an die Ausweis-App zwei,
Oder ruf mal noch ganz kurz,
Hier bei Theresa Olowski im Video-Event an und wackeln ein bisschen mit deinem Ausweis, damit wir wissen, wie alt du bist. Es gibt dann außerdem, das habe ich hier glaube ich auch schon mal erzählt, diese ähm Prüfziffer,
war das denn? An deiner Ausweisnummer das ist irgendwie so eine Prüfzufahre. Ich glaube in der Ausweisnummer ist dein Geburtsdatum drin? Nee, ist gar nicht in der Ausweisnummer. Es gibt auf dem Ausweis selber,
ist so ein so ein Code eingearbeitet, aus dem dein Geburtsdatum hervorgeht und äh so ein paar Dinge und am Ende ist so eine Prüfziffer dran, ja und wenn du äh eine einfacher Check, ob jemand,
18 ist, kannst du zum Beispiel darüber prüfen.
Dass sie diese Ausweisnummer eingeben, ja? Die hat allerdings eben die Prüfziffer hinten, ist nur,
eine Ziffer. Mit anderen Worten,
Du kannst dir eine Ausweisnummer ausdenken, die zum zu dem Geburtsdatum passt. Also es ist nicht die Ausleistung, weil das wird wieder korrigiert. Es ist nicht die Ausweisnummer. Irgendeine andere Prüfziffer. Ich hatte das hier kürzlich auch mal. Die steht hinten drauf in diesem ähm.
Zweite Zeile am Anfang.
Zweite Zeile, genau.
Im Prinzip Jahre Zahl, zweistellig äh Monat, zweistellig und dann Dings und dann einfach eine Zahl. Genau, also denkst dir irgendwas aus.
Genau, da könntest du jetzt ein Geburtsdatum ausdenken und dann müsstest du, wenn du richtig Pech hast, müsstest du zehnmal versuchen, bis du die richtige Prüfziffer hast.
Du kannst auch einfach zu deinem Vater gehen und dessen Nummer da einfach abschreiben und fertig.
Gib hier keine Tipps so und.
Oder zur Mutter, egal.
Das ist das ist das ist das, was die, wenn ich das richtig erinnere, was diese äh Medienwächterinnen Medienaufseherinnen äh gerne ähm,
hätten. So und da sagen aber natürlich die Pornoanbieter, irgendwie,
Dort hast unsere Kunden ab. So, wenn ihr ihren Ausweis eingeben müssen,
Da tönt die ab. Und ähm jetzt haben,
die äh haben gab es quasi ein Verbreitungsverbot, weil sie,
weil sie nur Warnhinweise haben, wo draufsteht, bestätige bitte, dass du achtsam bist. Und die der Verdacht besteht, dass es Leute gibt,
Jetzt halt dich fest, Tim. Die sind gar nicht achtzehn. Ja und die klicken trotzdem auf den Knopf.
Auf Porno. Unter achtzehn. Vorher haben die das gehört.
Soll ich dir, was soll ich dir sagen.
Angebote gibt.
Kann mir das eigentlich auch nicht vorstellen.
Wahrscheinlich langsam rum im Netz.
Mit dem Internet noch mehr machen kann als Hausaufgaben googeln. So aber.
Es es bleibt nix geheim. Es ist einfach.
Wir haben es jetzt obwohl ja äh das deutsche Bildungssystem sich so anschlägt, die Existenz des Internets als solches vor den Kindern so lange wie möglich geheim zu halten.
Ist ein anderes Thema. So jetzt haben sie sich beschwert, weil die also einen nicht ausreichenden äh Schutz hier haben und dann äh,
Gab es eine,
Beschwerde von diesen zipriotischen äh Pornoportalen gegen das Verbreitungsverbot ihrer äh Internetangebote in Deutschland und das wurde dann abgelehnt. Dann hat die äh.
Dann mussten sie vor das äh Oberverwaltungsgericht Münster,
Äh also vorher waren sie beim Verwaltungsgericht Düsseldorf, dann waren sie beim Oberverwaltungsgericht Münster und die Beschwerden wurden abgewiesen. Damit wurde der Landesmedien,
Anstalt NRW Recht gegeben, die äh eben diese Angebote äh beanstandt hatte und jetzt müssen wir aufpassen. Liebe Kinder, haltet euch mal die Ohren zu. Äh Pornhub,
YouPorn und my dirty Hobby. Äh und die Medien äh Landesanstalt für Medien NRW,
untersagt deren Weiteverbreitung in Deutschland,
solange gibt's zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder sie entfernen die pornographischen Inhalte, was die Webseiten wahrscheinlich,
in der Nutzerbasis schrumpfen lassen könnte oder eben äh sicherstellen, dass nur Erwachsene,
zu erhalten. Äh diese äh dieser Beschluss, jetzt erstmal das Oberverwaltungsgericht, ist nicht anfechtbar. Es gibt aber noch äh getrennte Hauptverfahren.
Wenn die sich jetzt weiter weigern, ein äh Jugendschutzsystem zu installieren.
Könnte das zur Folge haben, dass sie dann eben bei deutschen Zugangsprovidern gesperrt werden. Dann hätten wir,
werden wir also einen guten Schritt weiter in Richtung Netz sperren für Porno sein.
Also brauchen wir gar nicht uns so über die ähm über die Österreicher lustig zu machen.
Das äh gibt's in Deutschland auch.
Bin ich ja mal gespannt, wie das ausgeht.
Und dann werden aber weiße weiße weiße wer dann knatschig wird wahrscheinlich? Die über 8zehnjährigen.
Weil sie jetzt ihre Codes eingeben müssen.
Entweder wenn die einen äh äh wenn die ähm wenn die sich dieser Verfügung beugen, die Anbieter dieser Webseiten, ne.
Ja, ich meine, irgendwann werden sie sich dem wahrscheinlich beugen.
Ich es ist ein es ist ein ein sehr schwieriges Thema, was wir jetzt wahrscheinlich in seiner Gesamtbewertung hier nicht äh,
nicht vollständig äh.
Erfassen können, ob das jetzt ob da wirklich dem Jugendschutz gedient ist, wenn man diese Seiten,
weniger verfügbar macht, also im Sinne von dass dass die dass dann wirklich nennenswert weniger Jugendliche an diese Seiten kommen, weiß ich nicht.
Gleichzeitig ist es natürlich so, dass ähm also das geht ja hier auch ein bisschen um den ähm,
um um quasi den den Schutz der heimischen äh Pornografie Wirtschaft.
Meinst du?
Na ja klar.
Ich habe äh auf jeden Fall nochmal nachgeschaut, aber hier Theresa Olowski, der Verlag scheint sich mir zu äh geben. Ich glaube, Frau hat ist ein Re.
Hat sich zur Ruhe gesetzt.
Ja ja. Ist ja auch schon alt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was was was jetzt ein Deutscher ähm ähm Anbieter wäre.
Deutscher Anbieter. Also Produzenten gibt's sicherlich äh eine ganze Reihe so äh.
Ja, aber jetzt wirklich, wer so ein Ding in Deutschland hostet, müsste es ja verrückt.
Ja das weiß ich nicht.
Da muss ja wirklich verrückt sein. Hm, aber es gibt auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge Seiten, wo man nicht nach seinem Alter gefragt wird.
Und dann zum Chat eingeladen wird. Habe ich hier gerade gegoogelt.
Ja, bevor du jetzt zum Chat eingeladen wirst auf diesen Seiten, lass uns lieber über äh Cyberresilienz reden.
Schon längst dabei Tim. Okay, also net schwer in Deutschland. Dann ähm,
will die EU-Kommission will Cyberresilienz haben,
Und das klingt jetzt noch nicht mal,
so völlig daneben, geht aber jetzt auch es ist erstmal eine Idee, ja also und zwar der Cyber Resiliance Act,
Und das könnte, wenn also ich will jetzt vorsichtig, ne, das werden die schon irgendwie hinkriegen, das wieder zu verhunzen, aber das könnte
eine äh durchaus eine Reihe an Forderungen des CCC theoretisch umsetzen, so wie es sich anhört.
Entwurf soll äh,
bald äh veröffentlicht werden, war sogar schon angekündigt äh September 20021 haben wir wahrscheinlich sogar auch damals darüber gesprochen. Ähm,
Hier soll es jetzt darum gehen, dass es Cybersicherheitsanforderungen für den gesamten Lebenszyklus von Produkten gibt. Also ähm dass die.
Beim Design und bei der Entwicklung und bei der Fertigung,
Sicherheits äh Anforderungen erfüllen, bevor sie das an den Markt bringen und dann Schwachstellen während des Lebenszyklus des Gerätes äh zu,
überwachen und durch automatische und kostenlose Updates zu beheben. Ne, das wäre die Update der Updatezwang oder die Update-Verpflichtung, die wir,
haben, äh die wir seit Längerem fordern, ähm dann geht es darum, äh dass,
eine koordinierte Politik zur Offenlegung von Schwachstellen passiert, die also die Meldung von Sicherheitslücken äh erleichtern soll. Das äh soll bei der äh bei der Novelle der Richtlinie für Netzwerk und Informationssicherheit, der NISS
Äh zwei äh stattfinden und äh Produkte mit bekannten Schwachstellen sollen gar nicht erst,
in Verkehr gebracht werden dürfen. Ähm also es sollen Regelungen gefunden werden, dass es also grundlegende Anforderungen gibt ähm,
die unter anderem eben wenn sie nicht erfüllt sind, den Zutritt zum europäischen Binnenmarkt nicht ähm ermöglichen.
Und tja, das klingt schon mal ganz interessant, wenn man das jetzt vernünftig.
Ähm wenn man es wirklich vernünftig umsetzt, ja? Wenn man also sagt, okay, pass auf, hier ab äh.
Ab äh nächstes Jahr darf Brother den Scheißdrucker den Dinus halt nicht mehr verkaufen, weil der hat einen offenen und den kann man nicht abschalten. So, das wollen wir nicht, ja? Und das wäre dann durchaus mal.
Sinnvoll hier wirklich,
ähm klare Prüfvorgaben zu geben und ähm Rückruf und Sanktionen drohen zu lassen, wenn ihr eben ein klarer äh Verstoß gegen Sicherheits,
Standards, die aus guten Gründen etabliert sind, vorliegt.
Ja, welches äh hier richtig sehe, bezieht sich das jetzt auch nicht nur auf Geräte, sondern generell auf äh auch auf Software, also bezieht sich auch zum Beispiel auf Browser oder Passwortmanager. Ähm solche Systeme.
Auf alle Art von äh Devices, also nicht nur Rautar, sondern Firewalls, Artenviren, Software würde da drunter äh fallen äh et cetera PP,
Generell sollen hier wohl zwei Kategorien unterschieden werden, also einerseits eben diese Programme, Produkte, so wie wir es jetzt gerade aufgezählt haben und dann halt,
die Kategorie Betriebssysteme, Mikroprozessoren und das Internet of Things in Unternehmen,
die nicht als besonders empfindlich gelten. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was der Artikel mir damit sagen möchte,
aber wahrscheinlich meinen Sie jetzt in Bezug auf empfindlich sozusagen äh nicht hochproblematisch, da sie sich nicht für so ähm,
Also die Kategorie eins umfasst sozusagen Produkte, die so identitätsmanagement Systeme darstellen,
Wenn's halt irgendwie nur der der Kühlschrank ist, äh wo man sich nicht einloggt, dann ist das sozusagen,
nicht allzu ganz problematisch äh fällt. Von daher in Risikoklasse äh zwei.
Und für die Risikoklassen gelten dann unterschiedliche Anforderungen. In der höchsten Risikoklasse, die es aber äh da also in den,
natürlich machst du in den niedrigen Risikoklassen sagst du dann, okay, da könnt ihr euch selber zertifizieren und wenn ihr eben eure eigenen Zertifizierung nicht entsprecht.
Dann äh müsst ihr eben damit rechnen, dass ein ein Produktruf gibt,
ähm in im Rahmen einer der Art des Risikos entsprechenden Frist und ähm,
potenziell, wenn du jetzt grundlegende Anforderungen nicht einhältst, können äh Geldbußen passieren und bei den höchsten,
äh äh in der Hochrisiko-Kategorie muss es dann auch eine Bewertung durch Dritte geben, damit du überhaupt Zugang zum europäischen Binnenmarkt.
Ich muss mich noch kurz korrigieren, weil ich habe mich jetzt gerade äh verhaspelt. Also Betriebssysteme, Mikroprozessoren, das gehört alles noch in diese Klasse, in diese Kategorie eins rein und die,
Andere Klasse zwei, das sind dann halt irgendwie Computer, Desktopmobilgeräte, äh Aussteller digitaler Zertifikate,
Kartenlesegeräte und sowas. Ja, also auf kurz gesagt, es gibt auf jeden Fall zwei Kategorien, die werden unterschieden.
Ich bin da jetzt, ich also ich ich setze mich ja mit diesem Thema seit Längerem auseinander. Wir es sozusagen Auftakt in in meiner Wahrnehmungsfeld hatte das äh mit den,
mit dem Ausfall der Telekom, Router, Telekom, irgendwelche relativ günstigen Router äh,
Telebox oder was die da drauf schreiben, draufgeschrieben, Deutschland verkauft, dann gab's irgendwie diesen ähm Miraibonet äh,
Fall von so einem Briten und dann sind die Stadt gehackt zu werden, sind die einfach gecrasht, ja, was die denn da sogar noch behauptet hätten, das wäre eine Sicherheitsfunktion gewesen. Totaler Quatsch, so zu Sicherheit ist das Ding einfach abgestürzt. Äh also das war das war Unsinn
sorry, war richtiger Quatsch und ähm dann
ging es ja los mit der technischen Richtlinie Router, wo dann jetzt war das BSI erstmal eine technische Richtlinie formuliert hat und dann konntest jetzt kannst du dich am Ende quasi gemäß dieser technischen Richtlinie mehr oder weniger selber zertifizieren, dann kannst du irgendwie einen Adler,
auf deinen Router kleben und kannst hoffen, dass jemand dir 5 Euro mehr oder wenn wir realistisch 40 Euro mehr dafür bezahlt.
Damals habe ich schon mit einem freundlichen Herrn von der B Netz A gesprochen, der sagte, ja äh weil ich auch meinte, na ja so eine Selbstzertifizierung, die dann freiwillig ist,
äh löst ja nicht das Problem, dass,
trotzdem Billigprodukte, die diesen Standards nicht entsprechend in dem gleichen Supermarkt im Regal daneben liegen und günstiger sind. Und wenn man jetzt wirklich sagt, es gibt hier in der Produktsicherheit Probleme und dem will ich zustimmen, ähm,
dann muss man das eben als Markteintrittsvoraussetzung festlegen, sodass einfach überhaupt keine,
unsicheren Produkte mehr sanktionsfrei,
oder äh ohne Rechtsrisiko in den Markt gebracht werden können. So, das ist der positive Teil. Gleichzeitig ist es natürlich sehr schwierig.
Wenn man jetzt bei Hochrisikoprodukten Zertifizierungen durch Dritte verlangt. Ja, das ist äh etwas, was,
durch das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwei ähm zum Beispiel bei den kritischen Komponenten, äh die jetzt insbesondere im Bereich der Mobilfunknetze eine Rolle spielen,
der Fall ist. Ja, da da kannst du natürlich sagen, okay,
jetzt irgendwie, da sagt man dann, es gibt eine kritische Komponente in Ordnung. Jetzt muss die irgendwie geprüft werden. Das ist ja auch ne die die wird dann irgendwann Teil einer kritischen Infrastruktur der Bundesrepublik Deutschland und dann müsste muss was weiß ich der TÜV und,
nicht alles, dann dann gibt's drei Anbieter, die machen die die machen dann ein sehr, sehr teuren Pantest, an dessen Ende steht ja hier äh ist ist sicher, ne, das ist
Da wird's dann auch ein bisschen ja, vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, solche Regelungen werden auf jeden Fall für den,
ja für den normalen Konsumentenmarkt sicherlich überzogen aber überhaupt hier mal,
die Produktnachsorge auf den kompletten Lebenszyklus auszudehnen und,
Ja, verpflichtend zu machen oder mit Sanktionen zu belegen, wenn diese Nachsorge nicht stattfindet, äh ist wahrscheinlich eine ganz gute Idee. Aber.
Kann schon noch kaputt gespielt werden.
Werden die schon noch kaputt spielen, aber zumindest die Idee war schon mal nicht so schlecht. Ja.
Durch mit unseren Themen, oder?
Geilste war äh für diese Woche durch. Du kannst jetzt beim Doc Morris noch.
Auf Viagra bestellen.
Haben die das? Ich habe ich ich habe noch nie im Internet Drogen bestellt.
Jagd ist doch keine Droge. Ist ein Medikament.
Ja das Gleiche. Drogerie.
Kaufst kaufst du deine äh deine Medikamente in der Drogerie, ja? Oder nur die Drogen.
Da da wo ich wohne, muss ich habe ich eine Apotheke gegenüber und äh nach nachts nach äh Schluss habe ich hier auch äh fliegende Händler.
Online-Asse, Privatrezept und AU per App.
Eigene App hier. Schnelle Hilfe bei, hier Erektionsstörungen. So, jetzt gucken wir mal.
Muss ich erst mal sagen, ob ich 18 bin. Nee, stimmt nicht. Okay, Doc Morris, irgendwas funktioniert hier nicht mehr.
Na ja, kannst du ja mal mit beschäftigen.
Ins Oh. Da musst du auch einen Videocall machen. Schnelle Hilfe bei.
Nö, das ist nur eine Option, du kannst auch einfach ein Formular ausfüllen und sagen, irgendwie.
Achtzehn Euro dreißig.
Problematisch.
Und die haben aber irgendeine eigene App hier. Teleklinik.
Auf diesen Portalen durch durch durch Formulare durchklicken. Da musst du musst du niemanden ins Gesicht gucken.
Befindet sich ihr Hauptwohnsitz in Bayern.
Dann, dann machen wir nicht mit. Da gibt's nicht genug Strom.
Was hat der also haben die jetzt wahrscheinlich darf man in Bayern kein keine äh.
Oh, es gibt eine okay, das wäre super. Es gibt die Cranus Edera. Das ist die Potenz-App auf Rezept.
Was? Was macht die App.
Facharztbehandlung per Video zur Verschreibung einer Gesundheitsapp. 90 Tage pro Verschreibung.
Das ist also über diese Digas haben wir ja gesprochen als die Zerforschung, die aufgemacht haben. Das ist ja das ist ja der andere Teil, mit dem sie gerade das deutsche Gesundheitswesen plündern neben ihren Zuckerkügelchen, ne. Das das sitzt hier eine
App. Da musst du, wenn ich jetzt den Screenshots angucke, musst du Beckenbodentraining machen,
Cardiophysio und wöchentlich physiotherapeutisches Training.
Ah na okay viel Spaß äh äh dabei,
aus dem Augenwinkel lese ich übrigens gerade, dass die Twitteraktionäre jetzt die Übernahme durch Elon Musk äh genehmigt haben. Die wollen sein Geld.
Ja, hätte ich auch genehmigt, den Laden, der nur noch die Hälfte wert ist, jetzt äh.
Ja. Ja, ausverkauft. Der muss es wahrscheinlich jetzt doch noch kaufen.
Oh interessant offensichtlich ist der nee ist nicht die sind bei.
Ja irgendwo zwischen 41 und 24und Euro. Und.
Sind damit aber immer noch gute wenn ich das sehe 13 Milliarden weniger wert als Trump. Äh Trump äh mask geboten hat.
Ja ja, das wird nicht gut für ihn.
Würde ich auch machen. Äh würde ich jetzt prinzipiell auch erstmal sagen, ist okay.
Na gut, dann bestelle du noch ein bisschen, da äh online.
Nee, ich bestelle keine Digga. Ich ich will, ich will, dass das weg ist. Ich will das ist doch so ein Quatsch. Wirklich, eine Diga, eine eine eine Potenzapp.
Muss ja nicht die App kaufen. Du kommst einfach direkt das richtige Zeug.
Ich kaufe überhaupt nix bei denen. Ich wirklich, ich kaufe nix.
Mal gucken, was passiert, wenn ich sage, ich komme aus Bayern.
Ich habe Durchfall und komme aus Bayern. Mal gucken, ob die mir helfen. Okay, ich glaube, wir sind am Ende.
Definitiv. Leute, wir hören uns nächste Woche wieder. Bis bald.
Ciao ciao.